let's go next to our caller from the
5:02 area code who's calling today from
5:02 Jackie hey Jackie what's up I guess
my question is in your opinion what
would be the consequences if any for all
the senators who left the floor during
this you know impeachment trial yeah or
we're doing crosswords or obviously I
mean is there any repercussions if any
and isn't that lad the Chief Justice is
there yeah so Chief Justice John so so
what Jackie is referring to is that on
Wednesday which was day three of the
trial officially at one point twenty-one
Republican senators were just gone from
this from their seats and a couple of
them were stretching their legs but as
michael mcauliffe posted on twitter he
was in the chamber a lot of them were
just out they missed the evidence and
how are you to decide whether to acquit
or convict Trump if you don't even see
the evidence
so Chief Justice John Roberts presides
over the trial he is there in a
procedural role not to render an opinion
but it's procedural and that includes
enforcing the rules that are established
there so should there be some
consequence if the the Senators just
leave yes there should what should it be
Jackie I don't know I mean is it is it a
mistrial is it what I don't know what
the consequence should be but the most
important takeaway is the one you're
pointing out which is there's not going
to be any consequence they'll just all
vote to acquit and then we'll move on
and pretend they'll pretend it was a
fair trial yeah yeah and it's I don't
know it's just all really discouraging
I've always believed in the the justice
system in this country I served my
country and then I was a police officer
and I've always been in public service
and it's just it's just to see the
justice system do this and it's just
very disheartening and depressing
honestly yeah I mean the one thing that
may be a blessing in disguise is
hopefully enough people will realize the
molar investigation impeachment 25th
amendment on old Trump so if we want to
remove them we have to vote in such
overwhelming numbers in November that
foul play
can't get him reelected that's the one
path and it should be very clear to all
of us now well yeah I mean and I
understand I guess I have another
question what would your suggestion be
to someone like me who lives in Kentucky
where Mitch McConnell is my senator yeah
on getting people out to vote like my
age group I'm 33 yep so my age group you
know what would be your your suggestion
as you know how to best do that so
campaigns there's a lot of campaign
strategy campaigns know how to get
people out to vote volunteer for Amy
McGrath and I think that Mitch McConnell
also has another challenger but in any
case figure out who is the best shot of
defeating Mitch McConnell volunteer and
work on get out the vote they the
campaign's know the right get out the
vote strategies how to identify the
right people and volunteer and just work
to remove Mitch McConnell that's the but
at least in the if for the next nine
months that's what I would be doing yeah
I'm you know I don't work anymore I'm a
stay-at-home mom so I do have a bit of
free time so that is what I am devoting
the next nine months to is making sure
that McConnell's gone no that's a good
strategy at that that's working more at
the state level for sure and I think
that's a great idea Jackie I just don't
always feel like at the state level I'm
I'm making as much of a difference as I
don't know other places no I think
that's a fallacy so anybody at any
individual state level could say that
but if everybody in every state actually
got together the impact would be
absolutely absolutely massive Jackie I'm
gonna let you go I really appreciate the
phone call and and let's check back in
if you do indeed start volunteering
there and working
to get Mitch McConnel out I'd be
interested in hearing how that all goes